indignação fica aí e aí galera show no
canal hbo vocês mim está ótimo olha só
f4 quem leva desse quarto em machico
gravar os primeiros vídeos humilde né é
só como eu gostava mais quanto era pobre
aqui é diferente não tinha essa janela
que tinha uma janela aqui vocês vêem
diferença da mãe de vocês pra minha mãe
você troca o move a minha troca janela
de lugar nenhum é doida e hoje é dia 8
de março dia internacional da mulher e
minha mãe é a mulher né é claro eu acho
não sei se é e tenho certeza também
nunca viu ela pelada graças a deus se
pensa não é porque dá nojo é imaginar a
mãe ea irmã pela tarde já imaginei que
um homem pelado porque toda vez que a
imagem minha mãe e ela me dá vontade de
me virar do avesso assim o taleban que
em casa não quer condicionado nos outros
quatro só tinha ar condicionado do
quarto de mãe porque que a mulher é a
rainha la princesa isabel minha mãe é má
a barack obama do a mulher ela é tratada
como princesa o homem aguenta muita
coisa da mulher no 11 de setembro o mês
todo de aguentando coisa da mulher que a
mulher era exigente na verdade ela tem
que ser exigente a mulher tem que ser
bem tratada só que o homem sofre tanto
para deixar sair o flme passa cada raiva
eu acho que é por isso que a mulher
menstrua é um castigo que o universo da
é como se um universo de excessos assim
vai fazer um pássaro vai doar sangue
pelo pique que falar da [ __ ] cólica
cólica menstrual essa mulher se queixe
tanto reclama muito de cobre até a gente
nem sente a dor que ela está sentindo a
gente sofre só de olhar pra cara dela
ninguém corre corre que a única pessoa
que gosta de colo que as pessoas que
fabrica o atroveran como é tão morrendo
de cólica mulher o do desgraçado
morrendo de cólica
a gente treina amanhã diz que está
morrendo de cole porque dói dói mas dá
pra matar eu acho que estava a matar não
chega nunca cheguei um relógio com
alguém dizer assim o rapaz a [ __ ]
olha é tão bonitinho não é o exame
xinhua manhãzinha
mas ainda que tema que foi mesmo aquela
morreu outro ficou sabendo não e china
vai ser quanto aos em cima da cama
morreu de cole não trouxer a prover a
hora certa mas a mulher a finca a gente
aguenta muita coisa da mulher também a
mulher ela quer contar a mesma coisa pra
gente 15 vez por dia e das 15 vezes a
gente tem que fingir que é a primeira
vez que elas estão contando esse agente
ousar dizer que ela já disse que estava
completamente quanto mais nova casa das
7 horas da manhã achei um pouco a eles
assim amor não tenha claudinho o cara
diz temo tem a cloud ele pode nunca ter
visto a claudinha na vida dele ele diz
tem claudinho escola pegou os pais
namorado dela conversando com outra
rapariga que a mulher a tomada da outra
chapa boca para dizer que a rapariga
roubada conversando com ele terminar o
namoro a boca diz o meu deus eu perdi a
fé no amor pra dar aquela graça no
congresso isso 7 horas da manhã ao meio
dia ela vai de novo amor que foi um erro
não tenha claudinha tenho por que
aconteceu isso ela pegou o espírito da
morada dela não há desafio como estando
com outra roubada do periquito seco
depois que veio à conversa esther
minardi gol meu deus traz a corda pode
aqui para enforcá-lo eu não acredito
mais no amor meu de três horas a babá
está ela amou para já diz o que é meu
deus do céu não tenha com rodinha editei
que pelo amor de deus porque o cara que
tiver bem ele quer te ver feliz e não
vai quebrar o assunto dizendo que eu já
disse não ele vai escutar todas as vezes
e assim repete o 15 vez podia na tpm a
gente aguenta mais coisa porque a mulher
o rapaz que tem uma válvula que troca de
emoção a cada um minuto ninguém consegue
entender você dia chegou para mim e
falou assim a motor se que essa roupa me
deixa gorda disse não amor não ficar
gorda não só porque porque não ficava
mas a mulher quando ela pague tpm ela
quer que saia da tua boca que tá feia
ela achou um cinto puxou o bulls pulou
psiquiátrica e sair pela unb ela olhou
pra mim assim e agora eu que pensei
agora meu deus esse rapaz ou você
sincero nem vou ficar mentindo banana
que poxa eu nem para dizer sim é amor
assim fica um pouco gorda ela só fez
essa casa aqui ó beleza saiba quem eu
saí quando ia fechando a porta desse
trabalho e deixar aqui fala
é eu voltei fui abraçar ela diz que o
tribunal deu dois minutos eu passei
sempre e ficar nela porque ela pediu mas
quando eu dormi no trânsito não vai dar
nem um abraço disso o meu amor não foi o
que pediu para não ficar em torno de
mónia ela disso a moto me page cara é
baixou a cabeça e começou a chorar e foi
assim conta que para ele o meu deus do
céu mulher faz a gente passar por essas
coisas agora o porto acho bonito na
mulher é o companheirismo é um
companheiro que eu nunca vi na minha
vida estão a abandonar duas lado a lado
no meio da rua é um olhar pra outro diz
assim a amiga eu vou caminhar bem
devagarzinho na tua frente e itu olha se
eu tô suja ela vai
e aí elas fazem essa cena bem
discretamente na cabeça dela porque usou
não preste atenção nisso aí mas todas as
outras mulheres que estão do lado de lá
está menor e inunda pôde o vaso
menstruação parabéns a todas as mulheres
as mulheres está se você tiver dez anos
de idade tem calma que vai chegar o dia
da mulher em que termine já se verifica
hoje é dia da mulher também me deu os
parabéns agora parabéns assistir morto
em rades graça mulher coisa maravilhosa
que tem na terra ninguém vive ser mulher
ninguém vive sem mulher ateve a nem vi a
dúvida se a mulher porque sei de alguém
em quem se espelhar causa uma
sexualidade precisa da mulher todo mundo
cheio de mulher você é uma coisa
maravilhosa que deus deu me deu muito
obrigado me faz falta é a costela não
obrigado mesmo támbém mesmo todo mundo
que está conquistando seu espaço e
acabou na barreira do preconceito como é
dessa mulher topper mulher
proparoxítonas se você tiver gostar
desse vídeo já sabe que tem que fazer eu
gostei bem bonita aqui no youtube ajudar
demais sem volta a rolar no facebook eu
porque esse vídeo vídeo no dia da mulher
e curtiu a publicação e nos comentários
no facebook que marca sua amiga mas que
sua mãe marca sua avó marca sua amiga
que você já olhou estava sujo e marca
seu amigo que é desse jeito na tpm marca
seu namorado que o seu namorado que sabe
como você é quem quiser me seguir no
instagram smurfette no twitter aparece
na tela que é só você olhar
mas muito obrigado mesmo ter assistido
até aqui um beijão no coração de todas
as mulheres e todos os homens que deseja
ser mulheres também um beijo tchau
pare